welcome back to cbs mornings the price
of gasoline as we've been telling you is
higher than it's been in years but now
there's some new information about
people who have given up paying for it
in fact they are stealing it as an
alternative sheriff's deputies in tampa
released this video and announced the
arrest of six individuals all men
accused of stealing at least 60 thousand
dollars worth of fuel from gas stations
in that area alone it is a growing
national problem it's hurting businesses
and by extension hurting drivers let's
go to chris vancleave he's in
duncanville texas that's just outside of
dallas at a gas station that thieves
have targeted more than a dozen times
chris good morning i have so many
questions starting with how does this
even work
well good morning the thieves that hit
this place knew what they were doing
they had a special key but you can find
it on the internet they used it to open
up this gas pump and then within seconds
they were able to take as much gas out
of here as they wanted hundreds of
gallons at a time over and over again
and they did it all in plain sight
you're watching thieves making off with
truckloads of fuel stolen in the dead of
night from a dallas area gas station
was this hard for them to do no it was
literally they knew exactly they knew
what to do exactly they hit this station
16 times likely using a device to bypass
the credit card reader to steal more
than 7 thousand gallons of gas costing
owner mandeep singh about 27 grand they
will open this part up
and they will mess up the with the
system so they're tricking the system
exactly
as prices at the pump soar so are
reports of gas theft nationwide
the owner of this houston station
believes this minivan was equipped with
a trap door it parked over the
underground storage tanks and sucked up
five thousand dollars worth of gas
before driving off it's extremely common
we know that this is happening dallas
police sergeant richard santia-stevon
says these fuel felons resell the stolen
gas but just driving around with that
much fuel is a big risk it's a actual
bomb that's on the road and this is very
very volatile it's extremely dangerous
but it's not just gas stations across
the u.s bandits are drilling for dollars
going after the gas in parked cars newer
vehicles have a stopper in here that
makes it very difficult to siphon fuel
the old-fashioned way which is why the
bad guys have to go under the car and
right for the fuel tank
this man was arrested suspected of
drilling into the tanks of several
vehicles parked in front of atlanta
homes so i'm driving to go pick up food
stop up the gas station
start filling up with gas and this gas
is just spewing everywhere got
underneath the car looked at it and
there was a hole in the bottom of the
gas tank this pickup was still spewing
fuel as it was towed away for repairs
but it's a crime that can take a
dangerous turn in 2018 a man siphoning
gas from a u-haul truck in portland
sparked this blaze you can see him
running away with his pants on fire
now if you're a driver this is hard to
spot because the gas tank is under the
car so unless you get under here you're
not going to see that your gas tank has
been hit replacing a gas gas tank can
cost about a thousand dollars
aaa says where possible park your car in
your garage or in a secured parking area
if you're parking on the street look for
somewhere that's well lit and highly
trafficked tony
chris do the authorities think that the
thieves are using the gas themselves or
are they trying to resell it
they think that they are reselling it at
a discount so we've seen both here in
texas and in florida people running
essentially in a legal gas station and
reselling the fuel out of places like
their homes which could be incredibly
dangerous based on the amount of fuel
and how they're storing it
yeah it's a rolling bomb as one of those
guys uh pointed out chris thank you very
much how about that
no i mean you wouldn't think that now
before you go out if your car's on the
street you better get down on your hands
and knees and look under to see is it
are there any holes in it right now and
i understand gas prices are high yeah
dangerous ways to steal gas yeah very
risky careful one guy running around
with your pants on fire
it's on fire
uh chris great report thank you